what is the worst pain that you've ever
been in in your life like honestly ask
yourself what is the worst pain that
you've ever been in your life everyone's
been through pain like of some degree
some level like no one has had the worst
pain because there's always someone that
like the people in the medieval ages
when they've been in the iron maiden for
thirty days or the cow thing where they
get boiled alive the worst physical pain
I've ever been in in my life was after
my surgery and then to manage my pain
they had me in an epidural what it
epidural is it's a tap directly into
your spinal column at a certain vertebra
that injects a painkiller and anesthesia
directly into your spinal column so it
makes everything from that point down
numb so you can't feel a lot of it so I
had an epidural to manage that pain but
it was like it wasn't enough number one
right off the bat and then number two it
was making my legs numb so I couldn't
walk and that was a big problem so I
couldn't move at all I was like this
this is weird but okay I'll deal with it
I was gonna be bedridden for like two
weeks anyway in the hospital basically
the nurse and the doctors are like we'll
change this up like we want you to like
be able to walk and stuff so that they
changed my pain medication in the
epidural to something different cuz it's
just like a big bag in a machine that
slowly injects it overtime so they were
gonna change it so it increased the
painkiller and decrease the anesthesia
but there was a mistake in the in the
pharmacy and they decreased the
anesthesia and decreased the painkillers
so when they brought me the new bag I
was on no numbing agent and no
painkiller it was like basically a
saline drip into my spine and so I
started telling the doctors that I was
in a lot of pain like a lot of pain and
nurses and doctors would keep coming in
and they would look at the Machine and
they'd be like no it's fine it's fine
look it's fine you've got no problems
with it it's totally fine it's giving
you medicine it's giving you medicine at
the rate that we wanted to give you and
there's no issues with it so what it
came down to was I started more and more
just being like Doc's nurse I am in
incredible unbelievable pain I have just
a huge gash in my abdomen that's not
being medicated at all it's like I got
stabbed with a six-inch so
it really [ __ ] hurts and no one would
believe me no one not like the nurses
that I was with they kind of believed me
they kept going to the doctors but the
doctors did not believe me and it got to
the worst point where a doctor actually
came in the room he he was obviously
pissed off and just like to us guys just
trying to get more pain medication and
he comes in and I'm lying in the bed you
know I'm just in agony and he comes up
to me and he just grabs like full-on
grabs with his hand into my incision my
incision is from here to here like that
line that's the incision and he just
grabs around it and he starts feeling
for bleeding because he's like maybe
there's bleeding and he's feeling around
and he just grabs onto and I just start
screaming like just screaming in agony
because it is the most painful thing and
he gives me the most like like
derogatory look I've ever seen and I'm
just like I'm weeping tears it is just
the most agonizing thing he didn't do it
out of maliciousness now he did it
because he was checking for bleeding
obviously so he he was grabbing to feel
as if the incision was out like he was
he was palpating just to see if there
was something wrong with it and he might
have been doing it aggressively but then
again anything that he would have done
would have been incredibly painful and
so afterwards he left the room he
ordered that I needed to have valium cuz
he didn't want to give me more
painkillers but he wanted to give me
valium to like relax me and put me to
sleep and just like knock me out so for
those of you who know when I was doing
drunk minecraft sometimes when I would
get drunk and my face would flush like
with with blood I I would get this
splotchy mark on my neck like right here
and that's because that's a scar when
they gave me valium they they wanted me
to knock me out but I also had a central
line in my neck an arterial line in my
neck and what that is is it's a line
that ties in directly to your artery so
it can measure your heart rate blood
pressure and probably other things that
I don't know about but when I was on
valium and I don't remember doing this
at all I was so out of it that I dug
into my neck
I literally clawed and pulled and
scratched and scraped my neck until I
pulled the central line out of mine
and so I started bleeding incredibly and
then they rushed in they fixed me I
don't remember any of this
by the way I don't remember a thing of
this I don't remember doing it I don't
remember feeling it I don't remember
hurting like it all I remember is that
like when I when I finally came to I had
a huge like splotchy mark on my neck and
they were mad at me because I wasn't
supposed to do that so around that time
like I I was off the vet like I faded
out of the valium [ __ ] I was off the
valium and it was like three or
something in the morning I was at my
wit's end cuz it had been almost 24
hours that I was in incredible pain the
valium wore off I was in pain again and
it was just like this this never-ending
nightmare of pain no one believed me I
was in the worst pain I've ever felt in
my life and no one believed me
which like my my family were like
berating the doc my mom you guys have
seen my mom my mom was so mad like she
because she was a nurse like she's a
nurse and she knows this [ __ ] so she's
listed like constantly he's it's like
this is wrong is wrong is wrong is wrong
something's wrong please please please
so it was like 4:00 in the morning and
this nurse came in and I I called the
nurse again because the value more often
I was like please I'm in so much pain
like I was crying tears I was begging I
had nothing left I I just wanted
something some reprieve someone to
believe me and I was I was crying and I
remember I looked over to her and I I
said like I said to her I don't want to
die like I think I'm gonna die I think
I'm dying like this feels like I'm dying
and like I remember like I was crying
and even even this nurse like this a
nurse was broken up about this like this
nurse was literally crying and it's just
because the doctors didn't want to give
me anything else and it wasn't until
around morning when the shifts changed
and a new doctor came in that the
pharmacy realized that there was a
mistake the pharmacy said like a doctor
actually checked the prescription itself
with the pharmacy in the pharmacy was
like oh we dropped the anesthesia and
the painkiller
because I think it was when they were
gonna get a new bag like they were gonna
get a new bag of medicine and it was
supposed to be changed out and then they
were really like oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
and so after that it was an immediate
shift in tone like a work ethic
everything changed after that just to
put it in perspective of how drastically
it changed they they skipped out they
completely forgot about the epidural and
they just went straight to giving me
dilaudid
now dilaudid is also known as
hydromorphone it is it is a substance a
derivative of morphine that is 10 times
stronger than morphine and they gave me
dilaudid
every hour on the hour to manage my pain
that is how much painkiller I needed and
that's how much painkiller I would have
gone without and it was it was uh it was
better after that it was it was better
after that yeah it was it was much
better after that being on dilaudid was
very very very much better and so it was
from then on it was like this weird huge
state of being like I was just through
hell for 24 hours I was through hell and
I was in this weird moment where I
realized that was rock bottom yeah that
was rock bottom for me and so when when
I had that realization that that was
rock bottom it was kind of freeing I
realized like I had been through pain
unbelievable unbelievable pain that I'd
never experienced before in my entire
existence and yet I was still there and
I was fine and I was going to be fine
like I was I was through it and I was
gonna be fine
and and like I know that a lot of people
are you sure - sued or even my mom my
friends my family they were like you
should assume like I could've and I had
every legitimate reason to do that but
even then I was just like I don't want
to you know what I'm you know what I
mean like I don't want that to be the
defining thing about my life I don't
want to be I don't want that to be my
take away from it I didn't want anger
and revenge to be my takeaway from that
pained experience like it's not
something that I wanted to blame anyone
about I didn't want to blame myself I
didn't want to blame any of the doctors
like I didn't want a place fault on it
that wasn't my priority my priority was
after that I had this I had this like
clear clear intention that I needed to
do something with my life I needed to
make myself better I needed to take
control in some way shape or form
because I knew that life was always
gonna throw me curveballs and always
gonna knock me down and always gonna put
me through pain and I probably was gonna
be in more pain at some point in my life
that was even worse and like there have
been many people that have been through
worse pain than that and I have to keep
that in perspective to the goals that I
have to try to improve myself cuz I only
have control over my own life and even
that is up to debate like it's it's it's
something where I saw potential roads of
where I could have been I I saw
different paths that my life could have
taken and I saw different ways that I
could have lived my life and I chose the
one that allowed me to feel proud of who
I was as a person that that led me to
the road where I could believe that I
had some semblance of control of my own
destiny like forgetting the things that
aren't in my control not worrying about
the things that happened in the past
that knocked me down and moving forward
and always keeping my eyes on the
horizon to know that I can improve
myself until eventually I died it was
very freeing because I've been through
pain before I have I've been through a
lot of pain before I like as a kid you
guys probably know I had a jumping off
the top of the stairs contest with my
brother and I cracked my head open my
thick thick skull I cracked my head open
and it split and bled so much that it
feels like a whole bath foul with blood
my dad was one of those all of those
situations about
remember that being overly painful I
just got stitches and I remember being
in the doctor's office and my dad told
me about like I put the the like they
had this little like gown thing but it
had like a front bib so I turned it
around and I wore it as a cape and I was
just like ah superhero like it was I was
eight years old at the time but I was on
the doctors table I was like super your
dad and like he really remembered that
very fondly about me and it was like man
he's pretty tough and I was like yeah
and pretty tough and so um you know like
I I don't take away anything negative
about that experience or I don't even
remember me as a kid taking anything
negative from that experience and like
when I when I when I broke my arm later
on I was about maybe 13 or 12 it maybe I
was a younger like 12 or 11 let's say 11
I broke my arm I was with my brother and
we were playing a how far out the monkey
bars can you jump contest and I was
gonna win but I went out too far and I
fell and so I broke my arm and I broke
both bones in this arm and it was like a
stair-step like my arm went here and
then my hand was up here so it was this
is weird like thing so I remember
getting up from the ground and I don't
remember being in a lot of pain I
remember it hurt obviously I was like
something's wrong something's wrong with
my arm and so I like I don't even know
why I did it but my first instinct was
just to like that's not right I know
what it's supposed to look like so I'm
gonna fix it so I grabbed the broken
bone and I can die set it back into
place and then it started hurting that's
when it started hurting so I was like oh
[Music]
so like that's when it was like that
sickening pain where you feel like
you're gonna vomit like it was like that
was that was um the earliest moment in
my life when I was like that [ __ ] her
real bad apparently I did a good job
because after that like my dad took me
to the hospital and the doctor said hey
you know yo you did a pretty good job
you almost got it perfect you almost got
it right it's just a little off here all
fixed up for you and then he immediately
broke my arm again to reset it back into
place and perfect and that's why I'm a
perfection but I don't remember any
negative takeaways about that
remember I remember afterwards I was we
went back home it was when we were
living in a very small place a downsize
from our childhood home because my mom
and dad got divorced and we had to move
obviously we couldn't like finance the
house anymore
and so we moved into this small town
home it wasn't bad in any in any way
shape or form but I remember going there
it was one of the first times where
there was like within the first month or
two and I was in my bed and like I know
the doctor wrote us a prescription but
most pharmacies were closed like there
wasn't really a 24-hour pharmacy in the
area and like I told my dad that I was
like I'm fine you don't have to go I can
wait until morning like I can sleep for
this you don't have to get painkillers
my dad was like are you sure and like he
said I went to bed I was like after I
closed the door and I went to bed and
I'm pretty sure I was probably crying in
my bed because like it hurt obviously
and I was crying in my bed and then my
dad just like opened up the door and I
was like this must have been like 10
seconds from when he closed it I closed
the door on him because he was like are
you sure you don't want me to get
painkillers and I'm like it's like but
then my dad just went out and got like
he drove like 40 some minutes away to a
pharmacy and I just remember the the two
hours until he got back I was like this
is never gonna end a gurney unbelievable
agony like oh it's the worst thing and
they came back and like I I think they
gave me like I don't know like something
like vicodin or something like that and
it was just like as a kid I've never had
anything like that before so it was my
first experience with painkillers I
don't like okay it's very very sleepy
and I just went to sleep like I I don't
remember any negative takeaways from it
I don't remember any negative takeaways
at all from it I remember being
frustrated because it was really hard to
like sharpen my pencil with my arm like
that cuz I can't turn the thing I
couldn't like get my books like out of
the locker but that kind of worked out
well because the some of my best friends
in high school and school in general
they became my friends because they saw
that I was having trouble with my broken
arm and they were like let me help you
with that and it was like oh that's
nice and then like I became friends with
a lot of people I think drew Thiel was
the first person that like really came
up to me from that and then I got into
band because of that and it was like no
that that wasn't that wasn't really so
bad I mean even if it didn't lead to me
gaining friends like that like I don't
think it would have been bad at all I
only got to this point because of the
trials and tribulations that I've been
through and even through my college
years like up until the point where I
had that surgery that I told you about
the tumor removal surgery that was in
2011 I believe and before that like I
was still not sure who I was even after
that I wasn't sure who I was like I
didn't really solidify myself as a
person until maybe a couple years ago
like maybe a few years ago like it was
it was hard very hard and honestly pain
was a big motivator for it pain was a
big like resolution for it pain was a
good way of encapsulating it but only
because of my attitude that I took away
from the pain there's and and and this
isn't doesn't apply to everybody of
course there's there's certain pains
that you know you can't just like I'm
gonna have a positive attitude about it
but it's not even like having a positive
attitude about it like when it comes to
pain I did I wasn't happy that I had
pain like when I when I burnt my hands
this is another point when I had a lot
of pain I was cooking chicken wings and
I was heating up the pot with the oil in
it and I had my thermometer in there and
the thermometer broke which was stupid
because the thermometer was supposed to
go up to like 800 degrees so mercury got
in the in the pot so I'm like [ __ ] I
can't cook in this like Mercury's in
there that'll kill me so I stupidly put
it in the sink and I'm like I need to I
was gonna dump it and I'm like oh I
can't dump this down the drains that'll
be horrible it's so hot so I'll like
I'll cool it down first so I stupidly
elbow up the faucet dump water straight
into the 600 degree oil it instantly
flashes the oil bubbles over spills all
over my hands second and third-degree
burns all over my hands you can't see
the scars because I took real good care
of it but if I if it focuses right come
on focus right there you'll see just a
little scarring there
and stuff like that but I had second and
third degree burns on my hands so yeah
lesson to the wise don't put water on
grease don't put water in hot oil but I
was stupid it wasn't thinking just just
doing and so I remember I remember I ran
I I must have dropped it fell and
screamed cuz my brother was coming up
running the stairs
and he's like what happened and I
remember like I was sprinting to the
bathroom with my hands like in front of
my face I was like duh and then he was
up the stairs like what happened and I
remember running past him like Doppler
effect and everything just like just
like I was in the bathroom and I dunked
my hands underwater and it was so funny
at first cuz I was just like the
adrenaline was like oh and I was like oh
I'm fine like and then like I had my
hands under the water oh man Thomas I'm
so stupid like I put water in oil and
then the pain started coming and it was
like ooh and then it was it was weird
like like pulsating pain it would come
in like five second bursts and my hands
would cramp up for five seconds and then
release for five seconds it was very
rhythmic and very weird like and that's
when the pain would happen like the it
hurt like overall but then it would be
like and it would be like that cycle and
so my brother drove me to the hospital
and I was up at the emergency room
waiting camera only my hands and then
they're like please fill out this form
and I'm like right this was like please
just go over sit over there burn the
hands on like okay I want to walk around
because I hurt my hands just like I was
in so much agony like there were huge
boils on my hand like my hand was like
out to here with just this big boil
innocently and then finally some nurse
like behind the in the triage unit you
know the triage is like how they
prioritize people and the nurses like
get the [ __ ] back and so like I I go
back to the you know the emergency room
little rooms there and they put me on a
table and then then they make the stupid
mistake of they put a blood pressure
cuff on my arm
and that's bad when you have pain in
your hand because the blood pressure
cuff it squeezes it cuts off circulation
and forces blood down into the hand so
is it like look it hurts girls real bad
this hurts this hurts my hands they
answered Herbert oh my heart's real bad
and so they they basically it wasn't
until an actual doctor came in that it
are just like just like saw this on my
arm saw me in pain saw the boys Emily
[ __ ] I remember the panic on her face I
distinctly remember the panic because
she's like you know she pulls a curtain
back you know the emergency room was
like Ali my arm or like Ali oh my
stomach or you know occasionally if
someone actually has a problem they're
rushed in on a gurney blood everywhere
and they're sprinting in so usually when
they pull back the curtain it's not like
a huh situation so she pulls back the
curtains is like oh [ __ ] cuz I had to be
ambulance over to another hospital
because the emergency room I went to
didn't have a burn ward
so I went to the the Cincinnati
Children's Hospital for the that burn
and it was it was just a fascinating
experience where I had never been in an
ambulance before I now had morphine so I
was fine and so I was like that's all
it's all good like you know I distinctly
remember like even that pain like that
pain was pretty up there like if anyone
asked me on a one to ten scale that was
a ten pain like that was if anyone asked
me at the time that was a ten pain I
didn't know that I was gonna have more
pain down my life but I was like that
was a ten pain but every pain up until
that point I would gladly say I would do
that again like I don't I don't care
like I would do that again not
voluntarily but if I had to like I know
I could go through that again and I'd be
fine like even there cuz I remember what
happened was my mom
finally got off work and she came over
to the hospital at the the other
hospital cuz I believe she was working
as a nurse at the time so she was nearby
in the Cincinnati Children's Hospital
just in a different department and so
she came over and she was like brought
me McDonald's and I remember like I
couldn't exactly hold it well but I
could hold it with like my rested on my
thumbs and hold them with my pinkies
because I had bandages up all I'm down
my arm now I remember I was just
watching TV and just munching on a
burger know what I ain't so bad
I mean really like that that was because
it's not so bad beep-boop nurse more
morphine please it's just like but what
sucked after that what sucked after that
was I would I they sent me home
obviously I had to go home it's not like
I needed to rest in the hospital they
kept me two days there just in case
they sent me home they send me home with
a big old batch of like a big tub of
bacitracin which is basically neosporin
and every day I had to change out my
bandages twice a day and they said it
was very important that I changed my
bandages twice a day for the healing
process or else like it would be heavily
scarred disfigured and stuff like that
and I was like [ __ ] that [ __ ]
I don't want disfigured hands so I'm
gonna do this every [ __ ] day so I did
and that hurt like a [ __ ] because when
when you're when you're healing from a
burn wound like it's it's very important
to keep it like clean moist and well
like well bandaged so you know you don't
want air getting in there you don't want
anything like that so I would I would
have to rip the bandages off because the
bandages would cling to the newly-formed
skin so every single day twice a day I
would have to rip the skin off of my
entire palm on both hands like this
entire section down to here there were
some burns up here I would rip the
bandage off and hope that the skin
wouldn't rip with it and it was like a
50/50 shot of whether it was or was not
going to happen so I'd rip it off
hurt like a [ __ ] I had
painkillers obviously but you know it
still hurt I remember like 30 minutes
before I had to do it I would pop a
painkiller Billy and I would have to
mentally psych myself up to get ready to
do this and I was just like and then I
would put the bacitracin on I would like
make sure it's really well rubbed in
there I would put one layer of the the
topical bandage and then I would put the
gauze over that and I had these big
mummy hands I have a picture somewhere
of it but I don't remember where it is
one of my friends probably has it I
don't know it just never had any impact
on me as a person and me as like a human
being it was it was another experience
was like that sucked but I could do it
again like I could easily do it again
and it wasn't until you know I had my
tumor removed and I had pain beyond the
threshold that I knew I could tolerate
it was pain that forced me into a
mindset of desperation of just sheer
panic of not knowing if I was going to
even survive it like pain beyond pain
for longer than I ever could have
imagined myself tolerating that I had
this like realization that you know I am
very temporary I am unbelievably
temporary all of us are exceptionally
temporary we have very little control of
the forces around us we have less
control than we think we do and I could
have used that mindset to like really
like go into a pit of despair and
realize futility and like I could easily
see myself taking away futility from
that and going through this this this
experience and being like what's the
point like life is pain and stuff like
that but I didn't like because I didn't
like it completely disagreed with like
what I wanted out of out of life like
the the temporary nature of life really
really really was kind of freeing it was
it was it wasn't a bad thought it was a
negative at all it was a good thought it
was a good thought because if everything
was temporary then I only have a limited
amount of time to make a difference in
the world I only have a limited amount
of time to make a difference in myself I
only have so much time to be the person
that I want to be I only have so much
time to do the things that I want to do
I only have so much time to exist and
like the only thing that will be there
when I'm gone is what I've left behind
and I want to leave behind the best
things that I possibly can I want to
leave behind a trail of people that are
inspired by what I did I want to leave
behind the works that I've made I want
to leave behind the inspiration for
other people to strive harder than
they've ever striven before and to to go
farther than they ever thought they
could because I didn't think I could go
very far you know I thought I'd do well
I thought I'd be like okay but it wasn't
until that moment
the moment then I saw that things were
in my control not everything not
everything not everything can be in your
control very little things can but there
were some things that I could control
there were things that I could learn
there were things that I could practice
there were things that I could do things
that were within my realm of possibility
my potential the potential that you know
others saw in me you know I never
recognized and it was in that moment
that I saw the potential that I had in
myself you know I recognized that you
know people had said that I had a good
voice for a while and I was like maybe I
can do something with that you know my
brother was an artist sounds like maybe
there's some art potential in me you
know my my my inspirations I draw from
YouTube a lot I see that I'm like maybe
I can do that maybe I can do that it's
just like those simple ideas that simple
change of mindset even then I didn't
realize what it was and I didn't realize
where it was going to lead me all I
realized was that like maybe I can do
something maybe I can I don't know maybe
I could just show myself that I have
some potential and then I can act upon
it and then I can change my life and I
can improve where I am that's the entire
song of my life is just I'm going to try
and I'm going to try and I'm gonna fail
I'm gonna fail a lot I'm gonna fail a
lot but that's never gonna stop me
trying no one's ever gonna put me down
because no one's ever been through what
I've been through no one knows the pain
that I've been through and no one knows
how far I'm willing to go to do what I
want to do pain doesn't define you it's
how you respond to the pain that defines
you it's how you it's what you take away
from that that defines you it's it's how
you move forward in your life from pain
that defines you whether that's
emotional or physical I I don't believe
in the benefits of revenge I don't
believe that it leads to anything I I'm
a big
forgiveness and I which is odd because
I'm a very spiteful person but not not
excessively like just about as much as
anybody else but it's just like pain
it's so easy to lay blame for pain it's
so easy to point fingers when pain
happens it's so easy to bone triggers
especially at yourself like you could
point fingers at yourself for pain and
and that's a self-destructive cycle all
of it is like it's it's a
self-destructive cycle it will never get
better if you're always seeking a
release for anger you know if anger is
your only release for pain then anger is
all that you'll have it's like a muscle
that you train you you'll only ever have
more of what you put out from it like
you have more control over it than you
think there are some things that you
don't have control over obviously like
I'm not saying depression is just
something that you can control it would
never say that but there are like
takeaways you can bring out of it you
don't even have to be positive about it
because I sure as [ __ ] wasn't positive
when I was coming out of those surgery I
was [ __ ] angry I was [ __ ] pissed
off but I wasn't pissed off at any one
person I wasn't pissed off at life I
wasn't pissed off at like things I was
pissed off that I didn't take chances I
was pissed off that I'd gotten to this
point without having done anything I was
pissed off because this could have been
the end of me that could have been the
end of me you know I'm not saying don't
come out of pain all smiling like yes
and more please like don't do that
that's [ __ ] stupid
come out of it with a rationalization
that you don't need to point fingers all
you need to do is take the steps forward
that push you to what you want never let
anything be taken for granted don't let
any moment get away from you don't let a
single second get away from you because
I was nothing in my eyes I was nothing I
was I was just an average like everybody
like I had potential didn't act upon it
I was I was the sob story of wasted
potential you know and and a lot of
people you know can relate to that in
some way but I was ok with that
and a lot of people can be ok with that
and that's fine but
if you just take a moment to try and you
take a moment to go just a little bit
farther like absolutely anything's
possible
yeah no one is ever nothing I thought I
was nothing nothing